holy fuck so a let's get this straight
her headquarters is larger on the inside
than it is on the outside and she can
regenerate I think they can all
regenerate Pearl's a Time Lord
they're all fucking Time Lords uh Steven
the sword fighter
it's just Lee which I had to hit there's
no much door sword fighting with Steven
here although it was more mop fighting
than anything uh this woman starts off
with one elephant open well first of all
kid I think we both agree vet is
probably the cutest layout of Steven
just on garnets head and then when she's
like I can teach you sir fine oh yeah
there's a thing though our iPhone like
that was fun as horrible as when it just
trusted him with the little stars in his
eyes looking down just like a kitty cat
I was like that I just turned up like
bits fuck at the door and that was I'm
coming sir Ichigo I loved the fake I
couldn't it was it supposed to be an
anime or a say an actual movie ever
I thought maybe was supposed to be an
anime but it it hit certain anime
Trump's I like yeah like I couldn't tell
two dudes standing off then talking
about like oh my it cuz anime joints
were like an anime but it was done like
the setup and everything was more like a
live-action martial arts I know the
boobs open up a thousand screams I look
custom anime is always about the
super-secret ancient technique passed
down from my family from generation well
my Russian movies are with the fancy
yesterday like I mean I almost thought
they're gonna do hero ahead Cermak hero
feel and that went into more classics or
cheesy martial arts movies uh so I think
it's supposed to be like a mix of
martial arts and lightning anime kind of
kinda like everything has like a video
game feel but it's not straight up
hey this is this video game or this
video game though that was obviously
Final Fantasy way hold up that one toy
yeah don't you demons learning how to
sword fight from pearls hologram it's
only one person that can face pearl
that's as good as her
and that's her a little too good the
nerd cuz uh yeah she pretty much get
stabbed we we literally she gets stabbed
and we were like holy fuck yeah and then
when she just disappears in the puff of
smoke I swear brothers like yeah I first
out laughing
I don't clean get rid of yeah it's okay
everything's gonna be come on baby it
just move the last thing you think would
happen is such a great Joel after
already seeing such a very you know
jarring image really I mean it's only
done through the shadow but and even
then you see it go through and there's
no blood or anything but it's like it's
pretty jarring oh it's okay because she
can be generated only she takes her damn
time and uh if that's how long it takes
if you just get stabbed through the
stomach or something
she got fried in a fire that must have
taken a whole year to come I was gonna
say it's like it doesn't really take two
weeks or whatever it's like uh I haven't
been stabbed but if it only takes two
weeks to come back like I'm okay that's
still pretty impressive get stabbed
through the belt I'm just saying I I
thought she could have done a little
faster I think you know what I think she
was enjoying that having to work
you know as someone who is stopping the
only one Enoch in couple days I mean
maybe it's like no no hey I got this
town I got a I got a days three days in
fulfillment of their awesomeness oh but
um it maybe she just got sick of
cleaning up the damn place ha ha ha you
know what I'd take this two weeks is
appealing to them I'm living in my pearl
I'm happy in my pearl they never do
really explain why it took so long she
just kind of came back um and because
they're saying Mitch you see we've taken
her time on this one you know so it's
like I love amethyst being dragged back
in like yeah that we're where she eats I
guess what I think was just a cloud yeah
it's floating
oh that garden it like accidentally
releases just huh that's just um it's
funny because I don't know lying again
by the way yeah I'll be beside ya I'm
out under the porch ah yes hello it's
just for this weekís know these
Kentuckians good he's good he's good
yeah all right okay good good good to
know because you were flipping the fuck
out
no it's just why where they kept him
it's like they keep him outside which
doesn't seem very nice but he kept
crying in between episodes weird it's
like oh I thought you mess what the lion
was doing like the Cowardly Lion
no no it's way cool we're doing pink no
the lion is cool
Concannon pink you are green and the
exact opposite of cool
I would dare say lane ouch mm-hmm but
anyway back to the episode no I'm not
getting past the lane remark oh okay
that hurt me like the sword going
through her you know um
now I generate a couple weeks from now
get your shit together I can I'm not a
crystal gem though I wish I'm in a glass
cage of emotion I'm an abomination yeah
I'd say that was most important plot
point we learned that they can
rejuvenate yeah everything seems like
okay we're gonna do something really big
and really cool everything is just
setting up with all of this is just
setting up like the chess pieces which
is kind of cool because they're funny
and enjoyable but it is like I wish we
could hang it was just lesson about
patience
yeah wait for my real mommy leaves don't
try to use a hologrammatic mommy that
can kill you um that's a bad idea just
be patient and wait for your mother to
come back that's like that Animaniacs on
the dead parity of Power Rangers the PSA
at the end like a kid if a giant bug
wants to play with you just say no name
no giant bugs fighting for you and
remember no one has the right to touch
you in your chili dog area Sonic 6 um so
I won't say this when because out of all
of them I don't dislike any the
characters valve off I'm like pearl was
kind of like my least favorite cuz it's
like oh she's just the I know they need
her and stuff but she was just sort of
like girl
what's your the problem no I didn't
realize how much I actually got a perm
no I didn't realize how much I kind of
missed her until she came back and I was
going oh yeah here you need an actual
mother figure yeah you need some of it
you're not like the rest garnet is
garnet is more like your personal
trainer and I guess I'm a tough father
and yeah or the tough father and
amethyst is like that fresh lobby
roommate best friend that you're totally
cool with until like they completely
trash room and then you're like bitch
God garnet is very tough long it seems
like
and she's not me invited but it's like
very few words very yeah or it it's
they're also closest to an actual mother
figure I think steven has yeah like
actually besides onion boy oh yeah
clearly I mean tea
yeah you think he says all this until
how would it be a mother figure uh I'm
just a figure of you I just wanted to
bring up hope creepy ending boys yeah
I'm still not over that even I was so
great we're still it's gonna be a while
so I'm I got bring up by the way cuz
when I did the editorial for like I did
this one on our kid shows better now
than ever and I had a bunch of clips of
Steven universe arrow so oh my god did
he see into the future episodes does he
know it was just like a compilation that
I got and I didn't listen to a the words
or anything I just put you know it's
like hey here's the best up clip so I
mean don't worry I haven't seen any tell
you watch muslins yeah I don't listen to
words no just pretty pictures tuned out
I'd be like whoa the star eyes get in
there and stuff like this beautiful
teach me how to swordplay that I came to
the star eyes but for some reason I
thought I could in that second ah no
this was if you could I would have
fallen out of this chair or if I was
ever done anything like any kind of like
movie or show or say just for someone's
eyes actually turn into stars or
something oh don't know but I don't know
if a lot look about Peter's just scary
but we're getting on track here um so ya
know it was a good episode does kind of
show the importance of pearl and not in
just a oh my god she's not here to clean
up alright miss her bossy nursery she
came here to stab us with swords it was
something where he already kind of
appreciated her it's nice to have an
episode where somebody's gonna shit I'm
lying this light but you know how these
episodes work or it's not it's usually
like oh I'm really angry through you
know what I don't need you at all and
then they disappear and they realize
they did it was nice having one where
it's like no he legitimately appreciates
her and that he realizes even more how
important she was yeah so I like that
good good thank we're down there yeah
okay bye well you could be a little more
dramatic than that not if I can't do
star eyes my table no ah fuck